the kindergarten in the town of bhavari
nikiv was still smoldering as emergency
teams worked at the scene clearing
wreckage some of it scattered across the
playground earlier a helicopter carrying
nine people had crashed near the
building killing all on board including
Ukraine's interior Minister Dennis
monasterski Keith's mayor called his
death a huge loss it's the young guy
very patriotic guy do it a lot of things
for your brain and make a police reform
in Ukraine dozens of children were in
the kindergarten at the time of the
crash at least one was killed others
were injured a regular school day turned
into a tragedy Ukraine's president said
he was in unspeakable pain this
kindergarten is right in the center of a
residential era and people who live
around here in these apartment blocks
have been coming out to see what has
happened and most are in Shock
Alexander was nearby when he heard the
crash he filmed what happened next on
his phone
I approached the kindergarten and so
Harrison was on fire I went to check a
building where I have friends but when I
came closer a car exploded
I saw two dead bodies on the grass and I
was scared to go closer
on the ground then we found a helicopter
Wing it's a nightmare I'm speechless
police have opened an investigation into
the crash there's no word yet on why it
happened but it's clear that the death
of the Interior Minister and other
senior government figures is a huge loss
for Ukraine at a time when it's fighting
Russian forces the death of so many
others including children is another
painful tragedy for a country that's
already suffered so much Natasha Butler
Al Jazeera bravari Ukraine